رحلات ترامب تعددت قبل الوصول الى محطه
الانتخابات الرئاسيه العامه المقبل غير ان
رحلته الابرز التي تشوبها الكثير من
المخاطر تلك التي يخوضها في مواجهه القضاء
الرئيس الاكثر اثاره للجدل في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده بين مدافعين عنه
ومنتقدين له ابرز ردود الافعال اتخذت
اتجاهين متعاكسين حد الاصطدام والمواجهه
حلفاء ترامب يستميتون في الدفاع عنه
ويستنكرون ما سموها ملاحقات سياسيه
محاميته اكدت ان الترامب كل الحق في
الاحتفاظ بوثائق بعد ان رفعت عنها السريه
النائب الجمهوري جيم جوردان كرر ان
المحاكمه من تدبير معسكر الرئيس
الديمقراطي جو بايدن رغم ان لائحه الاتهام
تبنتها هيئه محلفين كبرى من المواطنين في
فلوريدا رئيس بلديه ميامي الجمهور فرانسيس
سواريز عبر عن امله في ان تمر الامور
بسلام
من الناس الى ان يكونوا مسالمين في اظهار
مشاعرهم النائب عن الوزيانز طلب من انصاره
ربط حزام الامان للانطلاق اما من ولايه
اريزونا فقد غرد قائلا لقد وصلنا الان الى
مرحله الحرب العين بالعين في المقابل قال
وزير العدل السابق بالبار الذي بات ينتقد
ترامب بعد ان عمل معه ان لائحه الاتهام
مفصله للغايه بار اعتبر مساله ان الرئيس
لديه السلطه الكامله لتصنيف اي وثقه على
انها شخصيه فكره سخيفه من جهته حاكم ولايه
نيوجيرسي السابق انتقد ترامب واصفا اياه
بانه رجل غاضب وانتقامي يتحمل مسؤوليه دفع
الامه الى لحظه اخرى مثيره للانقسام بشكل
غير عادي وفق تعبيره في اثناء ذلك البيت
الابيض يواصل رفض التعليق على القضيه في
حين يشير ديمقراطيون الى ان فوز ترامب
بالرئاسه
قد يكون امله الوحيد لتجنب السجن بلال
البشتين العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات